hi yes Garth Brooks plus one residency
kicks off tonight at the Coliseum at
Caesar's Palace the country Superstar
held a press conference ahead of the
opening and we were there to capture it
all so Brooks is no stranger to
performing in Vegas but the music
Remains the most important parts of a
show
I know this is crazy I think I'm excited
for them to see the music and what I
love about this place in this home is
if I'm working on something today if I'm
just starting it today guess what I can
play it up there tonight if I want to
because it's a laboratory let's see what
you think of this I need this let me
hear you see this kind of thing it's fun
and they will let me get away with it
during the press conference he shared
how grateful he is for his wife of
course Trisha Yearwood his friends who
will be performing with him on stage his
fans and the Las Vegas community so we
had a little fun when I asked him if he
would ever consider playing at the Super
Bowl he's never done it and it's going
to be here in Vegas
would you ever play the Super Bowl
halftime show oh shoot yeah but but me
and you will talk later on that because
we have been asked several times they're
sweet people and everything but who owns
what all that stuff these guys
understand what they have they know
their worth and their value and so uh we
kind of know ours too so I don't know if
we'll ever cross paths but they're
they're sweet sweet guys
while the Super Bowl is a bit of a wild
card something that is guaranteed is how
much heart and soul he puts into every
single show Garth Brooks kicks off his
plus one residency at the Coliseum at
Caesar's Palace tonight and don't forget
he announced new show dates for next
year for tickets and show times visit
ticketmaster.com forward slash Garth
Vegas and we we did mention earlier in
the show but additional dates for 2024
were just added so just an example of
the fan base that Garth Brooks has and
don't worry if you don't get to sing
along to I've Got Friends in Low Places
I had to do it this year there's always
next year I'll send it back to you